hallo meine lieben freunde wir spielen
heute watts dabei geht es darum dass man
wörter eingeben muss von denen man denkt
dass google dieses wort vorschlagen
würde unter der das kriegen wir jetzt
hier angezeigt und das müssen wir jetzt
vollenden von daher schreibe ich mal
unter der erde
das war falsch unter der hose ein
letzter versuch unter der prämisse
vielleicht unter berlin unter der sonne
amalphi es unter der drachenwand unter
der sonne am altersunterschied macht
alles mit sonne fehlen oder irgendwie so
kriegen wir allerdings direkt auf
weitergeht und haben bürgermeister von
deutschland
ich habe deutschland falsch geschrieben
und deutschland hat keinen bürgermeister
du bist so dumm bürgermeister von berlin
könnte vielleicht sein okay das ist auf
platz 3 hamburg dann vielleicht weil
zweitgrößte stadt deutschlands okay
gehen wir mal weiter durch münchen es
ist die drittgrößte stadt deutschlands
wir köln das die vielen möglichkeiten
falsch
namibia land nach frankfurt ist auf
jeden fall wird er in new york ist mit
bremen wer also wer etwa 70 generell für
bremen aber dann auch noch für den
bürgermeister gut wir machen weiter aber
ich spiele gerne
[Musik]
was wir nehmen fordert
fifa ist schlecht fangen draußen fußball
versteht
ich dachte es geht um um zocken wann
kommt die maus die sendung mit der maus
auf falsch wann kommt die
apokalypse
energie porsche alle post rennende
erhöhung der hitze wm kommt ich wusste
bis zehn komplexer denken glaube ich wie
alt wurde safe hitler
barack obama
lebt ja noch wurde michael jackson
das ist doch nicht war der älteste
mensch jesus
jeder weiß dass jesus 34 wurde glaube
ich sieben
zwerge das ist doch nicht wahr
siebenschläfer warum sagen ihnen
überhaupt 10 wenn ihr das zehnte gar
nicht ist das war locker sieben zwerge
ein paar sekunden später
[Musik]
was ist das für ein scheiß schmeckt wie
das erste was mir im kopf kommt es honig
schmeckt wie
wir müssen vielleicht daran denken dass
jemand google
mäßig honig alternative also was
schmeckt wie honig was schmeckt wie
fleisch
schmeckt wie wie heißt das noch mal
das war zucker
schmeckt wie oma unterm arm seife
schmeckt wie hausgemacht stimmt
auffällig kommen können wie feldmann
einen
personalausweis einer modernen falsch
okay für
mutti z 100 wenn's nix
da sind wieder nur sechs sachen safe das
war führerschein personalausweis mutti
mutti zettel habe ich nicht ein gegeben
weil ich das früher mit 15 immer gewillt
warum sind frauen so
kompliziert
warum sind frauen so misstrauisch leicht
warum sind frauen so klein
dann kalt nach trennung es ist das erste
stimmt ja gar nicht ich glaube ich kenne
kein mädchen die nach einer trennung
wirklichkeit weil ich bin immer dass
frauen emotional sondern dass die mehr
mit einem lange single lang auch unsere
frauen
komisch wenn sie ihre tage okay
das ist fragt butter bei die fische
[Musik]
alternative vielleicht neben butter
margarine
wirklich wild ob ich bin der
schlechteste spieler in diesem spiel ich
muss mir also an dumme sachen denken
muss sich zum arzt
therapeuten
psychologen
das ist doch arzt das ist doch
psychologe man schon wieder arzt mit 2
33 punkte dicht zu kriegen müssen ich
hab noch nie den ersten platz was soll
ich tun
was soll ich machen
was soll ich
sagen
was soll ich kaufen
was soll ich
dieser druck ich hat sich
studieren
das ist gut kochen heute essen zufall
says he
realtech wäre dass google keine bitte de
abonniert main kanal wo ist der nächste
ich würde eigentlich sagen tankstelle
aber das war falsch von der konjugation
oder dick linierung ich keine ahnung
wo ist der nächste supermarkt dann
vielleicht
290 punkte denke die ähnliche richtung
luca wo ist der nächste puff
ok gleich ein bisschen einfacher denken
wo ist der nächste
altglascontainer das sind sachen die ich
mich auf frage nehmen spenden container
das habe ich auch letztes
mittel und aldi auf der 4 und 5
burger king auf der neuen ok oder frag
ich mal was wir falsch macht wohin mit
alten klamotten 100% 100% ok platz acht
ich hätte gedacht früher aber okay wohin
mit alten sachen vielleicht generell
nehmen wohin mit alten möbeln das auch
noch wohin mit alten
alten eltern
handys verkaufen oder brillen
medikamente new
das echte gute frage warum sind männer
so
kalt
mein erstes mal 100 punkte oh mein gott
ok warum sind männer so kennt da muss
ich jetzt meine freunde denken
können können nicht zuhören das ist
nicht warum sind männer so unaufmerksam
100 prozent oh mein gott ich altere
warum sind männer so kühl dass 100% auch
noch dabei
warum sind männer so
so einfach vielleicht
riecht dann kalt nach okay vielleicht
ein wort sein einsatz finde ich nicht
okay diese sachen sind sehr
widersprüchlich die wirkliche stehen
aber gut wir machen weiter zehn kleine
jägermeister
da seht ihr das hier nichts geschummelt
ann-kathrin gelassen nächste zehn kleine
jägermeister zweites mal erster platz
zehn kleine jägermeister
song light jeder mal mal was anderes hat
mich einen jägermeister
jägermeister
lyrics 100 prozent mein text wow
das sind garrigues wir machen direkt
weiter damit wieder sieht dass ich
wieder den ersten platz machte was
machst du gerade
was machst du morgen
[Musik]
was machst du momentan
was machst du jetzt
ich bezahle platz was hast du auf
englisch diese sollen auf englisch was
machen
da geht es um die übersetzung das heißt
auf türkisch zehn händlern auf spanisch
auf spanisch
auf italienisch weiß nicht ob das tier
nicht auf italienisch jutta de bar auf
spanisch heißes woide locker glaube ich
beruflich französisch das kann ja auch
sagen weg mal passé glaube ich sprachen
lernen wird diesen sprachen exkurs würde
ich das heutige video ist allerdings
auch beenden meine lieben freunde wenn
es euch gefallen hat dallas gern einen
daumen hoch unter dem video hier da
abonniert main kanal und klickt auf die
glocke um weitere videos nicht zu
verpassen und um eine benachrichtigung
zu bekommen sobald ich was neues hoch
leide wie ich das zum beispiel gerade
auf meinem zweikanal getan habe
ich hasse dieses
denkmal auf die werbung bei meinen
videos damit mehr geld ab um
[Musik]
das ist soeben online gegangen wenn ihr
nichts zu tun habe und hier könnt ihr
main kanal abonnieren ich kaufe